so noble audio patent is 1030 it's a
10-inch convertible tablet it's actually
a multi-touch screen as opposed to
capacitive so you can smuggle it over
turn it into a tablet and it's very
touch like that I like the iphone as
opposed to the past resistive
touchscreens how to use a stylus or you
to eat at the press tab really hard so
it'll be interesting to see how this one
takes off pass convertible tablet and
not really succeed into the market and
windows seven is supposed to be
specially designed for touchscreen
capabilities with the latest atom n450
processor and it's going to end a screen
should be shipping for about five
hundred dollars so lenovo skylight it's
Villanova called a smart book it has an
arm-based processor which means it has
about the same processor as a lot of
smart phones out there the benefits of
having an arm-based processor is it's
pretty well powered and it promises
really long battery life so lenovo says
she'd have about eight hours of battery
life it also helps so the form factors
really did kind of like a smartphone and
overall
less than two pounds so it's really
light is going to sell for five hundred
dollars and when I was the Nobel applied
to sell of a team with the treaty
contract as well